حياته علاء عبد الفتاح في خطر السجين
السياسي المصري بدا اضراب عن الماء في
زنزته وكان هذا نداء شقيقته سناء سيف على
تويتر اخي شرب اخر كوب ماء في السجن من
فضلكم واصلوا لاهتمام بقضيته فالامر لم
ينتهي بعد يمكن انقاذ حياته
بالاضافه الى اضرابه عن الطعام منذ سبعه
اشهر لاحتجاجا على الظروف اعتقاله ياتي
قرار امتناعي عن شرب الماء تزامنا مع
مؤتمر المناخ في شرم الشيخ وبما ان
المعارض المصري على ارض الفتاح يحمل ايضا
الجنسيه البريطانيه تم انا رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ريتشي سوناك عائله عبد الفتاح
عبر هذه الرساله واكد انه سيختنم الفرصه
لاثاره قديمته
مشاركه المملكه المتحده في مؤتمر المناخ
تمثل فرصه جديده لتطرق الى قضيه شقيقك مع
سلطه المصريه علاء عبد الفتاح لا يزال
اولويه بالنسبه للحكومه البريطانيه سواء
كناشط في مجال حقوق الانسان او كمواطن
بريطانيا
ان ايامه معدوده
اذا لم تفعل السلطات المصريه ذلك فان موت
علاء عبد الفتاح سيكون في كل مناقشات
مؤتمر المناخ في شرم الشيخ يقضي على عبد
الفتاح وهو وجه بارز في ثوره عام 2011
حكما بالسجن لخمس سنوات بتهمه بث اخبار
كذبه يعتزم الناشطون المدافعون عن حقوق
الانسان اغتنام فرصه انعقاد مؤتمر المناخ
لتسليط الضوء على مصير اكثر من 60,000
سجين سياسيين في مصر